One single letter variation can be the
sole difference, from two people consuming the same
amount of alcohol. The same input, but
only one person shows the alcohol flush reaction,
while the other person doesn't. We have
the same input, but a different output. And
all due to a difference in the genetic
code. In theory, this phenomenon exists for virtually
any drug that humans interact with not just
alcohol. While pharmacology is defined as the science of
drug, that deals with their composition uses and
effects. Pharmacogenomics is the study of how a person's
genome affects the way they respond to drugs.
The goal of pharmacogenomics is to learn ahead of
time, what the best drug, or the best does of a drug would be for a person.
To better catalog new information that
is uncovered all the time. The pharmacogenomics
knowledge base or pharmGKB was founded and
created as an interactive tool for researchers
to investigate how genetic variation affects drug
response. Both with regards to pharmacodynamics and
pharmacokinetics. Simply type in the name of
a gene that affects the pharmacokinetic or
dynamic effect of a drug. And pull up the
entry describing what is known about it. Here you
can see right here, the very allele that we
just learned about. Position 1510 of the coding region
that changed from guanine to adenine. We can even
see the SNV varient with the SNV ID, rs671.
And we can click on that variant and see
exactly what the change is. Glutamate to Lysine. We can
even use PharmGKB to search for drugs. We should have a
lot more information for us about the drug and its affects on
the body. As well as all the alleles that affect its pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics. We'll learn more about Warfarin later in the lesson.